[Música]
escala en París Braulio Moro
[Aplausos]
Bienvenidos a una nueva emisión de
escala en París una emisión de radio
Francia internacional en colaboración
con la televisión Franz 24 en español La
destitución y detención del expresidente
Pedro Castillo tras su fallido intento
de disolver El Congreso el pasado 7 de
diciembre abrió una profunda crisis en
Perú a dos meses de distancia esta
crisis está muy muy lejos de ser
resuelta más de 50 muertos protestas
cotidianas de un país semi paralizado
son algunos de los elementos más
martantes de esta crisis la reemplazante
de Pedro Castillo la presidenta Dina
boluarte ha sido incapaz hasta el día de
hoy de salvar la crisis que enfrenta ese
país y al mismo tiempo tanto ella como
el congreso presentan un gran problema
de
conciencia y de rechazo entre la
población siete de cada diez peruanos
rechazan hoy en día tanto a la
presidenta como al congreso para
intentar comprender de mejor manera esta
situación Contamos con la presencia en
nuestro estudio de El embajador de Perú
aquí en Francia Rolando Ruiz rosas señor
embajador Muchas gracias de haber
aceptado esta entrevista para escala en
París gracias a usted señor Moro por
esta oportunidad de dirigirme a la de la
audiencia de esta prestigiosa cadena
pública francesa muy amable los hechos
están claros señor embajador decíamos en
diciembre pasado el presidente Pedro
Castillo intentó de manera ilegal
destituir al congreso esto resultó un
fiasco a partir de ahí fue reemplazado
por la actual presidenta Dina boluarte
su presidencia que es constitucional ha
sido rechazada por un sector muy
importante de la población peruana y
llegamos hoy a dos meses de protestas
decíamos con un país semir paralizado
Cómo se va a resolver esta situación
cuando ni el congreso ni la presidenta
quieren renunciar
bueno en primer lugar el país creo que
está camino a felizmente retomar las las
actividades en muchos sectores estos no
han sido paralizadas pero sin duda Hay
la necesidad de una solución a esta
crisis política y hay que destacar en
primer lugar que el detonante de esta
crisis política es este intento de golpe
de estado del presidente Pedro Castillo
El Siete de diciembre el presidente no
solamente anunció un mensaje a la nación
su intención de disolver El Congreso de
la República sino de intervenir el poder
judicial el tribunal constitucional y de
gobernar por decreto este golpe de
estado es el que detonó esta crisis Y
por consiguiente El Perú está superando
este proceso tratando de preservar lo
que es sustancial a la vida democrática
que es el estado de derecho y la
preservación de la institucionalidad
constitucional en ese sentido la
presidenta boluarte que fue como manda
la Constitución
designada para suceder al por el
congreso de la República
ha buscado como solución a esta crisis
el adelanto de las elecciones generales
a la cual usted se ha referido también y
esto implica en el caso del Perú una
reforma constitucional Pues los mandatos
son por cinco años la presidenta para
esto ha enviado dos proyectos de ley uno
primero en diciembre pasado que fue
aprobado Y que ahora por una revisión
del Congreso Esperamos que haya una
solución pronta pero lo que iba Es que
la solución en cauce constitucional es
el adelanto de estas elecciones frente a
lo que es la aspiración probablemente
central de la de la población que es una
renovación del la representación
política actual al mismo tiempo da la
impresión que la presidenta va dando
titubeos qué quiero decir con esto el 28
de enero ella declaró nos vamos todos
Hay que hacer elecciones anticipadas
esta semana ha dicho no mire renuncia no
está en entonces Parece que va de un
lado para otro el hecho es que
efectivamente la comisión de
Constitución de El Congreso ha decidido
posponer el debate sobre las elecciones
hasta el mes de agosto esto quiere decir
que en el mejor de los casos
eventualmente
las elecciones podrían darse el año
entrante y la crisis iría abierta bueno
sin duda en este momento la
atribución de la Reforma constitucional
que conduzca al adelanto de elecciones
está en manos del Congreso de la
República y esperamos que esto pueda ser
resuelto en los plazos que la población
o la mayoría ha expresado interés en que
así sea confiamos que la clase política
en su conjunto tenga
la madurez suficiente para encontrar una
salida que atienda este este interés y
que desde el ejecutivo la presidenta ha
reiterado por lo mismo afirmándose como
un gobierno de transición la importancia
que se fije la de forma que se
establezca la reforma constitucional que
permite este adelanto de elecciones
embajador decíamos Esto empezó el siete
de diciembre pasado en dos meses de
acuerdo a las cifras oficiales han
registrado al menos 50 muertos la
presidenta en su momento declaró que los
responsables van a ser juzgados se sabe
que ha habido detenciones la Comisión
Interamericana de Derechos Humanos la
comisión de derechos humanos de Perú
hizo un llamado a la presidencia
planteando El problema del exceso de
violencia de la parte de la policía se
sabe que varios de esos muertos son de
la policía hay ya detenciones Cómo van a
ser juzgadas estas gentes bueno el
proceso de investigación judicial
corresponde a las entidades de la
administración de Justicia Empezando por
el Ministerio Público que ha empezado
investigaciones en todo el país
especialmente en los lugares donde estos
hechos de violencia se han producido
quiero en primer lugar quiero Además
este expresar mi profundo pesar y
lamento por las circunstancias en las
cuales han tantos ciudadanos peruanos
por diversos motivos en especial en el
curso de las protestas creo que esto nos
ha sumergido en un duelo en el país se
decretó días Igualmente de duelo por
esta consternación pero no quepa duda
que el desde el estado se ha apoyado Las
investigaciones del Ministerio Público y
ya que usted lo ha mencionado en el
campo internacional que es el que nos
compete desde cancillería se activaron
inmediatamente los mecanismos de
protección de Derechos Humanos como
expresión del compromiso firme que tiene
el Perú respecto de la protección y
promoción de los Derechos Humanos así se
ha tenido dos visitas de la Comisión
Interamericana de Derechos Humanos
presidida liderada por su vicepresidente
y relator especial Eduardo rolón así
estuardo ralón así como de la oficina
del alto comisionado de Naciones Unidas
para los Derechos Humanos No hemos
tenido aún sus informes pero como ellos
mismos han dado cuenta han recibido
desde el estado Igualmente las mismas
facilidades para para desarrollar sus
visitas para entrevistarse con los
deudos de estos fallecidos con heridos
con la sociedad civil y por supuesto con
altas autoridades del estado en este
sentido desde el ejecutivo hay un total
apoyo y facilitación a las
investigaciones que permitan esclarecer
estos hechos investigar sancionar
procesar y sancionar a quienes resulten
responsables
hay garantías que así sea por supuesto
embajador hasta el pasado 27 de enero
siempre de acuerdo con cifras oficiales
se habían registrado pérdidas entre
trescientos y cuatrocientos millones de
dólares
de las distintas Fuentes del gobierno
peruano dicen que cada día se están
perdiendo entre 50 y 60 millones de
dólares el centro principal del turismo
de ese país Machu Picchu estuvo cerrado
un cierto tiempo hasta el día de ayer
había 87 bloqueos en carreteras que son
activos todavía como ven esta situación
quiero decir la prolongación de la
crisis necesariamente tiene
consecuencias hay problemas en la
frontera con lo sabíamos hay problemas
con los transportistas
la renuncia de la presidenta de los
miembros del Congreso no ayudaría a
resolver esto de una manera más
acelerada Bueno sobre los el impacto
económico de la crisis sin duda es muy
importante a pesar de que el Perú en
esta coyuntura internacional que ha
afectado Más allá de los hechos en el
Perú a muchos países ha mantenido
niveles de de inflación y crecimiento
por encima de la región pero sin duda el
la situación económica tiene un impacto
como usted ha dicho está más o menos
estimado ahora por el Ministerio de
economía casi para hablar en euros en
casi 500 millones de euros no pero
Incluso un sector que es muy muy
importante en en el en la relación
bilateral con Francia que es el turismo
Francia es el segundo emisor de turismo
en el en el Perú ha tenido un impacto
visible casi el 50% de las reservas este
semestre ha sido han sido canceladas lo
que tiene Pues un perjuicio
especialmente justamente para las zonas
del Sur del país donde ha habido la más
fuerte protesta tuvieron lugar las más
fuertes protestas y que es el principal
receptor del del turismo internacional
este hay que notar Igualmente Que buena
parte de la actividad en cuanto al
tránsito por carreteras en fin ha sido
restablecido y progresivamente Esto va
normalizándose ahora bien sobre la
salida constitucional creo que la la
propuesta del ejecutivo para el adelanto
de elecciones de manera que pueda
tenerse un proceso electoral que
conduzca a una salida no solamente
democrática sino que permita el
electorado peruano un proceso de
reflexión para que esto Esta crisis
política no vuelva a repetirse es
importante cabe tener en cuenta que en
el Perú en las últimas décadas El
Ejecutivo nunca ha tenido mayoría en el
congreso no es la primera vez que sucede
eso así es que El Ejecutivo gobierna en
en minoría en los últimos en el último
esta situación se ha vuelto muy crítica
muy
antagónica en una polarización por lo
demás no está exclusivamente concentrada
en el Perú esta polarización la vemos en
diversas democracias de América Latina
en fin de occidente no así que se trata
también no solamente de de salir de la
crisis sino que esta salida de la crisis
sea dentro del Estado de derecho del
marco constitucional pues esta es sin
duda este sin duda un valor primordial
su defensa es tarea de la de la clase
política de la sociedad que
mayoritariamente quiere a su vez una
situación de paz hablando de de las
cifras expresadas que esto puede hacer
encontrado en breve vuelvo al tema de
las elecciones porque necesariamente
Esto es lo que puede como usted bien se
menciona permitir una salida
institucional a la crisis que vive el
país el 22 de diciembre la el congreso
voto en favor del adelanto de las
elecciones
pues ha habido modificaciones en la
presidenta llegó a plantear en su
momento que se podrían hacer este año
concretamente para el mes de octubre
el hecho de que se pospongan ahora que
la comisión de constitución del Congreso
diga nos volvemos a reunir en agosto y
veremos cuándo lleva esta Cuándo se
resuelve esta situación hace que el
mejor de los casos se vaya esta
situación hasta el año próximo la crisis
seguiría abierta en este contexto
Confiemos como decía al inicio que el
congreso pueda encontrar una salida para
atender esta demanda del adelanto de
elecciones que reitero sigue siendo la
propuesta desde el poder ejecutivo ahora
para explicarle a la de la audiencia en
el Perú El adelanto de elecciones no es
necesariamente producto exclusivamente
de una ley sino que implica una reforma
constitucional y la reforma
constitucional obliga a que esta sea
aprobada en dos legislaturas
efectivamente la renuncia de la
presidenta no ayudaría en esto pero la
renuncia de la presidenta es una opción
que digamos
es una opción de tipo que puede hacer
atendida desde el ejecutivo si se
considera que esta salida facilitaría
ello pero por ahora la situación de la
convocatoria del adelanto de elecciones
corresponde a la reforma constitucional
propuesta con estas informaciones nos
llegamos ya al final de esta escala en
París no me queda sino agradecerle señor
embajador Rolando Ruiz rojas embajador
de la República de Perú ante la
República francesa su presencia gracias
por habernos acompañado soy yo el que
les estoy muy agradecido señor Moro y
hasta una próxima ocasión Saludos
Igualmente a la de la audiencia
seguramente a ustedes les damos una
nueva cita aquí la próxima semana en
otra escala en París
[Música]